it's hard to keep up with Sam Smith's
identities but last night's Grammys they
as Smith now prefers to be called
identified as Satan the performance
while many Jews especially amongst the
American Christian fraternity which are
210 million in America send them to take
Cruz said it was evil
well one of the scariest moments for me
wasn't Sam Smith as the devil it came
with Madonna's General appearance she
seemed not to have got the memo that
Halloween's in October
but are they Sam Smith pushing artistic
boundaries or just pushing the limits of
good taste shocking for the sake of it
outraging because why not it sells
records or join me now to debate all
this it's Master Rowan who performs as
tripping Jupiter and the YouTuber and
commentator Lauren Chen so Lauren Chen
let's start with you I mean it's called
outrage this Sam Smith's performance
last night he'll be quite pleased about
that because quite clearly a bit like
Madonna is heroin part of his stick is
deliberately creating outrage because it
fuels interest and headlines and sells
records
no you're absolutely right and people
have said that this is a controversial
move by Sam Smith this is not at all
controversial within Hollywood and I
want to be clear that Sam Smith did this
specifically to upset the American right
and Christians everywhere and to Virtue
signal to his fellow Hollywood members
and elitists that don't worry he's on
your team he hates all the things that
he's supposed to hate if he actually
wanted to be controversial in Hollywood
what he would do is actually come out in
favor of Traditional Values because we
know that would never happen in a
million years or he would heaven forbid
actually do something that's critical of
maybe Islam that would genuinely be
controversy but of course because that
would be popular among leftist elitists
he's not going to do that this is
actually in a lot of ways the safest
thing that Sam Smith could have done
yeah I mean now tripping Jupiter do I
call you tripping Jupiter or Madison
which one would you prefer you could
call me man stuff Master thank you for
being on the program
um this reminds me a bit of the met the
Met Gala in New York when they all
suddenly wore crucifixes one year and as
a Catholic I wrote a column saying you
know what you wouldn't be doing this to
the Islam uh religion why would you just
do it to Catholicism and to Christianity
and that reminded me again exactly what
Lauren said about last night yeah you
can dress up as Satan and prance about
having a bit of devil worshiping just to
deliberately outrage 63 of Americans who
are Christians but given he wouldn't do
that with other religions which are
likely to lead to more serious
repercussions for him I thought it was a
bit cowardly if I'm honest
I mean I don't think there's anything
cowardly about Sam Smith
and you know if Lauren's suggesting
that they are doing this just for
publicity as far as like their identity
goes I mean people struggle their entire
lives with identity and the fact that
they can come to a place where they
feel secure enough to let it out and the
public is an amazing thing and a
beautiful thing and a really important
thing as far as the the the red glitter
hat with the devil horns and I'm sorry
Ted Cruz if anyone looks at Sam Smith
and thinks the word evil I think that
they might frighten a little too easily
as far as as far as the Catholic Church
goes I mean
um I can't think of a better uh
you know religion to criticize or to
tweak or because I mean I mean there's
like decades and Decades of of child
sexual abuse that got covered up so they
don't really have a right to stand out
and be outraged when they but they're
also decades there are decades and
Decades of Islamic fundamentalist
terrorism and the point that Lauren was
making I think rather powerfully was
that you wouldn't get Sam Smith mocking
Islam in a performance
because again I mean you wouldn't say
it's cowardly I'd say that is an example
of kind of cowardice because we all know
he wouldn't do that and what he did last
night I'd say the he I think he called
they they what they did last night uh
was a deliberate Act of provocation to a
group of people who represent nearly
two-thirds of America and I I'm I find
that an interesting strategic decision
you know this is this is somebody who
wants to sell records in America you
know it's a it's a risky strategy to
take on that number of Christians and
mock their religion in that way
I don't think anybody's religion was
mocked at all and this album by Sam
Smith is it's phenomenal
um it's got really positive messaging to
it but like if you're going to talk
about artists pushing boundaries this is
what great artists do you go back to
David Bowie he was attacked and vilified
when he burst onto the scene Lady Gaga
over a dozen years ago or more coming
out same thing you could go back to I
mean so are you going to tell me you
don't like David Bowie you don't like
Lady Gaga because people were unhappy
and the interesting thing is with these
icons go back to Catherine Hepburn right
when she was doing movies she wore pants
and people freaked out the detractors
who push against people who push gender
boundaries nobody remembers their names
I'll come back to Lauren but the problem
I have with Sam Smith is that they can't
seem to work out what they are so we
went through a period where he was
identifying a apparently is a straight
man then he came out as gay and everyone
was applauded and then within I think 18
months uh he decided he wasn't a gay man
anymore he was going to be non-binary
gender fluid and what does it be called
they it's quite hard to keep up Lauren
Chen not to be disrespectful to they but
it is hard to keep up with Sam Smith
because every 18 months or so he seems
to like a chameleon flip into something
some other new identity so and then we
have to respect that those titles that
they now want
now you're absolutely right and it's
interesting because I was looking back
to interviews when Sam Smith first came
out as gay and he actually back then
would say things along the lines of
there's more to me than my sexuality I
just want this to be normalized this
shouldn't be a whole thing which I mean
by today's 2023 standards that almost
makes him sound like a right-wing
extremist the idea that his sexuality
shouldn't Define himself but fast
forward to today apparently he's gotten
the memo that the trendy thing is to
come out as uh some sort of trendy new
gender every other day and I just want
to say in regard to Sam Smith dressing
as the devil that's that's not part of
your identity your fashion choices are
not part of your identity Sam Smith
deciding to in his music video where a
corset doesn't mean he's non-binary it
all all it means is that he's desperate
for attention has absolutely no sense of
fashion but also I'm talking to people
around him right and talking to people
desperate of attention
um master I just want to show you
Madonna's head at the Grammys and just I
just wonder is this an example when you
look at Madonna at the Grammys last
night of where plastic surgery takes you
if you're not very careful
if you're asking me I am not an expert
on plastic surgery so I prefer to go
back to Lauren's corner I just have a
question for both of you have we got the
picture of Madonna sorry there we are
yeah
sorry go on master
well I I wish her well she's an icon
she's done great things in music and
influenced a lot of people my question
is why are conservatives the ultra
conservatives especially the only ones
who are obsessed with what people wear
obsessed with how people identify and
Obsession we've run out of time but I
can answer one question I'm not a
conservative so if that helps you that
great to have you both come back again
soon